[music playing]
One, two, one two three four!
I remember when I was a young man my
momma took me to the store and I was
scared out of my mind as I
stared at that dressing room door
I was like
what if the pants are too bright too dark
too baggy too light too big
wrong cut or too tight
and mom was like "just be yourself son"
whatever you choose'll be right
WELL
It's like she knew my very soul 'cause
the pants I bought that day would change my life
I left that store with a uniform that I was wearing
when I met my wife and
at my first punk rock show
and when I touched my first boob
and the first time I read Thoreau
I did it all in my
t-shirt and jeans
that's right, it doesn't mean
anything
people who know me know
that I try not to say too much just with my clothes
and if you wanna get to know me, man
we're gonna have to talk
so that you can find out who I am
t-shirt and jeans
[more music]
well jeans are prety great they're
durable and comfortable
they're pants made out of plants
so it's hard to argue they're unethical
and a shirt can say a little or a lot
I'm a fan of unironic images of things I like
like giraffes or my YouTube friends
or bands
or chickens
Jesus, nerds, or bikes
But if you really wanna know what I love
most about this wardrobe
Is that it tells you very little
about what lies beneath these clothes
just by looking at me
You would never know if I'm a
thousandaire or a billionare
I wanna tell you with my mouth
not with the clothes I wear
well I think it's odd how when we rebel
we put on uniforms
like eye-liner or fancy pants
that come factory pre-torn
it's easy to say
that a guy must be a certain way
just because he dresses off-beat
and a sub-cultural short-cut
might be what he's going for but
it's always gonna be incomplete
yeah, we're never really ever gonna know
what that means
which is why I wear
t-shirt and jeans
that's right, it doesn't mean
anything
people who know me know
that I try not to say too much just with my clothes
and if you wanna get to know me, man
we're gonna have to talk
so that you can find out who I am
we're gonna have to talk so that you can find out who I am
yeah we're gonna have to talk so that you can find out who I am
well we're gonna have to talk so that you can find out who I am
John, we're going on tour.
We're starting in Kansas and going a bunch of places in Texas
and then across Arizona and up California
It's a pretty short tour, just 10 days.
We're touring with Wheezy Waiter's band, the Driftless Pony Club, and Harry and the Potters,
who have probably the best live show I've ever seen
The shows are fun and laid back and we do our best
to pack them full of interesting stuff.
Hank Green and the Perfect Strangers go on last
but I sort of MC the whole evening. It's very fun.
Tickets are on sale now for all of it except El Paso
I'm sorry, El Paso. We'll figure it out, though, and I'll let you know.
We'll have some great merch: shirts and posters and a flash drive that contains every song I've ever written on it,
and if you pay in cash we'll do our best to give you your change including a $2 bill that I have signed.
'Cause that's weird.
We have a great time and all these people on Twitter agree!
I got some testimonials - just searched "Hank Green concert"
It's fun, come along!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.